wait we we'd be allowing you to take how
much of our first like year essentially
years worth of royalty checks for
how did you get your movie electric love
on hulu so we uh
we went through a distributor gravitas
if i can say and uh and we had a really
great experience with them um you know
this was a few years ago and we had a
friend who was another producer and uh i
think he also does a little bit of
distribution himself and he had made the
offer to kind of introduce us um you
know gravitas i believe is is pretty
open to
uh filmmakers submitting their work to
them i think you know this has been a
little while i'm pretty sure their email
is like up on their site and they they
kind of welcome filmmakers a sense their
work in
so uh we we had the deal with the
gravitas
they were
great you know for for i was the first
time uh film
dirt film producer uh seeking
distribution and so for me i thought the
experience was really really good you
learn plenty you you i have always been
negotiating so for me i always knew i
was going to like be trying to play
hardball and retain as much ownership
and yada yada um really protect your
protect your your investment your your
project um and but i i really had no
complaints with them like i thought that
they were fantastic i thought that they
got the movie out there that they liked
and we went with them globally and so
they got some great uh overseas licenses
for us we we were out
in the uk and a friend of mine saw our
movie on tv it was like playing on
repeat on the tv all the time over there
my friend called me up he was like
you're on tv and i was like oh my god
yes i made it it's happening
but that we got the news like probably
within a few months of securing the deal
with them that they had negotiated to
deal with hulu and we were just
over the moon i mean over the moon you
know and now we're
huge hulu fans like we're like hulu
everyone get hulu watch it it's on hulu
everybody watch and we love it and i
think hulu is doing some really cool
things with horror
um and in independent films too and so
yeah and documentaries and so i'm you
know i'm gonna hopefully be trying to
knock on that door again for our
distribution of val
very cool
did you also try to get it on other
platforms like netflix and apple tv or
hbo well so yeah gravitas
does all that this is something new that
i'm learning is um you know you might
try like i as the producer would want to
sort of circumvent the distributor
because they certainly take their
portion although they do a little bit of
work there for you as well but you you
it wouldn't be the worst thing in the
world to go directly to netflix or apple
tv and i'm sure that that's possible but
we didn't have the connections to go
directly and i believe now if you aren't
already uh
you know having a relationship with that
company you do it's like required to go
through uh an intermediary like a
distributor like gravitas
um
and you know like i said this is
people have all different types of
experience i can only speak to my own
but that's what our experience was
when did you sign with your distributor
i want to say we sold we we signed uh
with gravitas for electric love around
the fall of 2018.
um you know and even then we we had the
deal locked but that doesn't necessarily
mean that the the movie is going to be
out for viewing and that was something
that we learned you know through doing
is like you think you sign with the
distributor that's that like when's my
movie's gonna be out next week right
but they didn't release it until
the spring of next year so we were just
waiting all all winter like waiting
excitedly for our movie to come out and
it was really exciting when it did we
had this whole big happy dance at home
did you have a sales agent
we did not
i know there is a ton of value with
sales agents
at this point for us especially with the
budgets that we've been working with you
know it really behooves us to try our
best to do
everything ourselves because then we can
retain ownership and you know sales
agents certainly come with fees and
either percentage fees or they
are tacked on with marketing expenses as
well
we did have it as a long discussion we
were really interested in a particular
sales agent
but eventually once they talked to us
about what the marketing fees were going
to be we were kind of thinking ourselves
like wait we we'd be allowing you to
take how much of our first like year
essentially years worth of royalty
checks for
you to like kind of wine and dine people
over in con and and i say that like just
with my own my own perspective i think
there's a lot of value to sales agents
and a lot of value to them having a
marketing spend to go out there and
really like push your movie and he might
have even been able to get us a little
bit more but
at the end of the day it didn't it just
didn't feel right it felt better to
retain ownership and and go with
something that was maybe going to be a
leaner marketing strategy but lower cost
did you receive any upfront money
we were offered in advance
but it was contingent upon them taking
an extra five percent of ownership
and you know that for it just kind of
depends on your situation you might be
like nope i have investors i need to be
paying back straight away or i need this
money now and in that case you might be
in a situation where you need to go
ahead and accept that um but for us we
were
you know we were just able to go ahead
and say we would rather retain more
ownership of the movie don't worry about
the advance we'll wait for the first
check and then you realize you still
have all these delivery costs so forget
about the first check i'll see the
second one maybe
because delivery fees i'm sure seasoned
filmmakers understand delivery fees in a
way better capacity than i did but at
the time i did not know that i did not
know about delivery fees with
distribution
and it really rocks your world in the
indie space you know you think like
you're going to spend how much money
delivering this and i mean for me i
negotiate every little thing i make sure
i get the best rate as a producer i
stretch every dollar
and in these distribution or i'm sorry
delivery fees delivery fees um
you know you're thinking like
did you negotiate that like i don't
think i don't know if they are you know
i'm not saying anything anyone did
anything wrong i'm just saying like i
certainly i if i had the capacity to
ever get into that space
you know god willing that would that
would be fun but
it's really not not where my heart's at
so i'll let the the distributors do what
they they need i'll uh make sure to cap
uh
delivery fees in the future and they
were they they were like capped to a
reasonable amount but i'm just saying
like as someone who was not aware that
that was a thing to see that like bottom
line price tag you're like
that's like twenty percent of the film
and you like kind of freak out a little
bit
um yeah and then you just kind of get
through it and hopefully lock some good
licensing deals
how long did it take you to receive your
first payment and how frequent are the
payments
um i want to say so to to like jump off
of the delivery fees that kind of ate up
the majority of our first check if not
the entire first check
um
and then we received checks quarterly so
you know you'll it'll be uh once a
quarter closes then it's about 30 days
to let your distributor do their
accounting and then within like a few
weeks after that you'll receive a check
in the mail
um and then they've been wonderful
that's something i can't say highly
enough for gravitas they are like a
schedule with with the checks and it's
been fantastic and they've locked us
some wonderful deals because what we've
noticed and again just our experience um
the licensing deals are where we see the
bulk of our our money for smaller things
like amazon rentals you know kind of
itunes rentals
i think we'd have to be like a keanu
reeves to really move the needle
financially there uh for now we see the
bulk of our our money coming back
through all these licensing deals via
different countries and
streaming deals like hulu
have you noticed one particular country
is very much into the film
i think our best like international
licensing deal was either
the uk or germany because we got those
deals and we were like oh germany eh and
then germany was great like they they
liked it they
had a decent deal over there the uk was
a little bit bigger and then our biggest
deal was domestic it was and and i think
that kind of speaks to to the genre
you know where it's like it's a romantic
comedy
english speaking you know it kind of
it's very i think it's just very much of
of america you know like it just kind of
feels
like the audience is here not to say
anything about internationally
international audiences i just think
that like the concentration of people
who would like the film were just us
based
what lessons have you learned from
distributing electric love that you're
going to take forward with foul
excellent question
um it's something i've been thinking
about lately because we're we're just on
the cusp of like getting some more
serious conversations going for
distribution of val
um i will absolutely be
looking for i'll be seeking like a
global distributor so we really liked
that we really enjoyed working with one
and one company to do the entire the
entire package we'll be putting a lot of
focus on the licensing so we'll be
talking to them about what their
projections are for different countries
and and this is a horror
genre film with val
so that i think can translate to many
more like you don't need to know english
to know how to be afraid you know you
see they might i mean obviously there
are subtitles as well but there's a
little bit more give there with the
story
um
and then of course like i was just
talking about delivery fees you know
really having a discussion with whomever
our distributor ends up being about what
are these delivery costs going to be
and let's make sure we have a reasonable
cap on them um like i said i think that
it was all fine with our last deal i'm
not saying anything bad about that it's
just it's more of like a revelation like
okay now that i know that i also took
that into consideration with this entire
film's budget you know i understand that
there's going to be this tacked on
amount which could be
i mean it can vary i'll give out like a
spectrum but to be something like in our
electric love range the delivery fees
could have been anywhere from
10 to 30 thousand dollars
we were kind of somewhere in the middle
there but
and i'm sure on a bigger budget film
perhaps more you know i can only like i
can only speak to what my experiences
have been and with val you know i have
kept that in mind what the delivery fees
might run and keeping that in mind when
we were
coming up with a budget for it and
trying to make sure that we kept that in
mind that even though we've our
production budget is this our post
budget is this don't forget about
delivery fees i mean they come out of
your first check unless you have a
distributor where you have a different
deal as of now
i only know indie filmmakers who absorb
the cost of their own delivery fees
what are some of the things that are
included in the delivery fees
it's so aaron is definitely the better
person to ask for this one but i do know
it's a lot of things where it's like you
need to get subtitles for every
different country that you know you're
going to be licensing around
every export and delivery on all these
different drives and there's the m e
track you know which is like these other
files one day let me tell you a horror
story about electric love with the
delivery fees because like i said i'm
i'm a thrifty producer i'm constantly
trying to stretch a dollar four ways
from sunday so
we find out that there's this fee that
we can pay on top of what we were
already paying to get
uh the
emini
something with like everywhere that
every time there was a line like someone
speaks in the film
you needed the time code the exact
precise time code of the start of the
line and the end of the line and then
like some other information for every
single line
and i think that the price i don't even
know what it was going to cost it's
going to cost something like maybe a
thousand maybe a couple thousand who can
remember this time
but i was like i've got some time i'll
do it and i did it and i did it and it
was the worst thing ever no it wasn't
but you know i sat down i had like some
music blasting and i treated myself to
some chipotle and i like just just
bunkered down and did it and it blessed
aaron he would come by every now and
then give me like a little massage or
something and i would i would complain
but in the way that you complain where
you just want someone to be like oh yeah
it sucks yes i would do that this sucks
and he would give me all the charity
that i needed at that moment and i would
soldier on and keep going
and i think it took me like two full
massive days maybe even three and when i
finished it i was like i don't want to
hear anything else about these delivery
like this is my contribution to saving
money in the bottom line and i do aspire
to be a producer that uh can afford to
go ahead and hire someone to do that for
me that's tedious work it was it was
tedious but you know at the same time
not the worst thing because your
your brain kind of goes on that
autopilot where you just get to relax
and you're just like
it's very boring work but like you said
tedious yeah
so yeah
not great but
i'm proud of it now i saved money for
the project and that is one of the
things as a producer that i i continue
to be proud of myself for is i know how
to really stretch the dollar really like
be
very particular about the budget stay on
target with the budget and if we have
new expenses
well if i can learn how to do it i'll go
ahead and i'll do it myself and you know
submit the the correct work that needs
that's being needed um that's good
well that's that's really cool man i
should have made a video of behind the
scenes of that like
all three days or two days whatever i
know right
it exists very clearly in my memory like
i know that day i remember exactly where
i was sitting exact everything i'm like
oh yeah and we had a filmmaker friend
who was
almost paralleling us in distribution
like he was going the same distributor
and he was doing the same thing and i
would text him being like have you
gotten this file prepared he's like i
think i'm just going to hire someone to
do and i was like
shakespeare's friend friend lily and my
friend like all right but i did it
myself pat me on the back you know what
i mean that's a lot
it was yeah